Bolivia's embattled President Evo
Morales is calling for new elections
after a regional election monitor
reported irregularities with October's
voting results demonstrators Q's Morales
of rigging the last election and have
staged multiple protests police units
have marched alongside the
anti-government protesters president
Morales is a leftist and he is Bolivia's
first indigenous leader Morales is moved
to call for fresh polls marks a sudden
reversal after he had previously claimed
victory in October's ballot all right
let's bring in our correspondent Johan
Ramirez he's standing by for us in the
capital of Bolivia that would be La Paz
no Johan the election monitoring group
OAS that's the Organization of American
States said that the October vote should
be an old why is that I mean what did
the group find the Organization of
American States has announced that they
found in this audit they have been doing
it for the last two weeks they found at
least 1,700 irregularities so with this
they cannot verify the results of the
election that's why they they recommend
a new election they found at least
350,000 votes that could be no legal
votes so a big difference that could
change completely the result of this
election that's why they recommend just
not just a new election but also to set
up a new electoral commission to
organize this event I mean correct me if
I'm wrong but this certainly seems like
the president is backtracking now he'd
been defending those election results
now he's calling for a new election is
that true yeah the opposition the
opposition leaders have announced that
they had not spoken out not yet but here
we are in front of the headquarter of
the government of Evo Morales so we've
been talking with deputies of the
opposition they have been saying that we
are not going to participate in this in
this call for fresh elections they are
supposed to
choose the new electoral commission and
they have been saying to us that they
are not going to do that they want the
resignation of Evo Morales they keep
firm in this in this they just want over
Morales out of power and we are awaiting
the announce of Luis Fernando Camacho he
is the leader of the committee because
this is the like the civilians this
civil society which has been taking part
of this opposition protests and he is
supposed to talk in 30 minutes and
Carlos Mesa who opposed Evo Morales in
the election is going to talk in about
one hour so we don't know exactly what
they are going to say but it looks
unlikely that they want to participate
in this first elections announced
forever
- ever Morales now given what you just
said I mean do you think that a new
election will will satisfy the
opposition and satisfy the protesters or
will we see more protests I don't think
so
really for the last week they have been
asking for the resignation of ever more
others and now the evimer list looks
looked like week announcing a fresh
election I think they want to go beyond
of this and I don't think is going to
change the what the opposition has had
been asking for so we have to wait a
little bit to see what what they
announced but it looks really unlikely
that they are going to accept this call
Johan Ramirez reporting for us in La Paz
thank you very much